chers amis chers à boxer avertis ou pas
le temps d le temps d ouais c'est bon
j'ai mis ko c'est fini boxe foot arts
martiaux sports de combat et sports co
sont souvent vecteur d'intégration mais
il serait également propices à la
radicalisation en 2010 7 829 personnes
ont été signalées dans des clubs
sportifs français pour proximité avec
des thèses jihadistes selon lui clac à
l'union de coordination de lutte
antiterroriste à plus de six mois après
la publication d'un rapport
parlementaire sur les services de l'état
face à la radicalisation pour en est il
exactement
le milieu sportif est il plus touchés
que d'autres pourquoi on en parle après
le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur arte france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre match le 27 juin 2010
9 les députés les républicains eric
diard et la république en marche eric
pouya ont publié un rapport
parlementaire sur les services de l'état
face à la radicalisation
sept mois après où en sommes nous on en
parle avec sur ce plateau patrick karam
vice président de la région ile de
france en charge des sports du mouvement
libre de valérie pécresse vous est
également docteur en sciences politiques
est à vos côtés
william gasparini vous êtes sociologue
professeur à l'université de strasbourg
spécialisée dans l'étude du sport et
auteur de l'ouvragé le sport dans les
quartiers pratiques sociales et
politiques publiques aux éditions pef 1
messieurs bonjour et merci d'être avec
nous avec moi sur sur ce plateau je le
disais sept mois après la publication
d'un rapport parlementaire sur la
radicalisation au moment où emmanuel
macron le président de la république
veut mettre fin au communautarisme ou
est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans le sport patrick
karam
écoutez d'abord il faut bien distinguer
les phénomènes parce que le la note de
des services de 2015 ne faisait pas la
distinction entre ce qui relève du fait
atteinte aux valeurs de la république et
laïcité d'un côté et à la radicalisation
de l'autre qui mélangeait les deux
phénomènes
il yad'un côté de questions importantes
mais deux questions différentes avec des
degrés d'importance tiff qui varient il
ya la question de la laïcité des valeurs
de la république par exemple une fille
qui porte le voile
quelqu'un qui rentre sur un terrain et
qui ne fait pas le saluer jigoro kano le
fondateur du judo quelqu'un qui refuse
de serrer la main des femmes ça peut en
être encore une question liée à sa
pratique religieuse quelqu'un qui
observe et qui veut imposer ses règles
par exemple qui se douche avec avec un
sur eux avec des vêtements parce que
pour les questions liées à la pudeur
islamique qui ne veut pas être nu tout
ça c'est des questions qui peuvent
interroger s'il veut imposer sa règle à
d'autres pratiquants qui peuvent
interroger des problèmes de
ici tu es valoir la république via la
question de la radicalisation en soi et
de la radicalisation c'est tout ce
processus qui peut conduire quelqu'un se
mettre en marge totale de la société
parfois même basculer vers l'action
violente
moi je lui dirai radicalisation
islamiste islamique si vous préférez
mecs qui peuvent là pour le coup vous
présenter quelques dangers c'est à dire
il y à un certain nombre de signaux
faibles qui peut vous permettre
d'identifier quelqu'un qui est en voie
de radicalisation
vous avez un jeune pratiquant qui
jusqu'à présenter un intérêt dans son
club qui allait boire le pot avec ses
camarades qui embrassait les filles et
cetera et cetera qui d'un seul coup
s'isole commence à tenir des thèses
complotistes commence à refuse de serrer
la main des filles de les embrasser qui
commence
comment vous fait et bien là on vous
avez un tel cas nous nous avons mis en
place un système d' alerte avec des
lanceurs dallaire qui viennent du
mouvement sportif qui doivent sur le
terrain dans les clubs intervenir et
nous alerter nous envoyons nos
éducateurs nous envoyons des éducateurs
lorsque c'est un phénomène lié à la
laïcité et aux valeurs de la république
quand il s'agit de la radicalisation ne
sont pas là pour des radicaliser et ça
peut aussi avoir un impact un effet sur
le le pratiquant et des autres parce que
ça peut aussi rehausser les départs de
violence et dans ces cas-là ce que nous
faisons c'est que nous faisons du
signalement qu'en sais tu ce début de
radicalisation nous essayons avec nos
éducateurs de prendre en main le jeune
le mineur est avec les parents pour
l'accompagner vers vers d'autres
horizons
vous venez de parler de notes
william gasparini vous avez été chargé
d'étude par le cnrs en 2016
qu'est-ce que vous avez recueillis sur
le terrain je suis assez d'accord sur le
fait qu'il faut éviter les amalgames
parce que le terme radicalisation c'est
un peu un mot valise et ont même
beaucoup de choses qui ne reflète pas la
réalité donc moi dans leurs idées
la radicalisation c'est de l'islamisme
alors c'est ça
donc il faut déjà dire que non pas de la
radicalisation islamiste dans le sport
qui est une forme de processus qui
conduit à des actes violents
c'est le fait de ne faire aucun
compromis et de revenir à la racine
d'une idéologie de l'islam radical
donc la première chose effectivement que
moi j'ai fait c'est de distinguer d'une
part à la radicalisation islamiste dans
le sport où il ya quelques cas alors
effectivement parmi les tueurs du
bataclan dans leur biographie individuel
on a des traces de pratique sportive
mais une fois qu'ils rendent dans le
processus de radicalisation il quitter
club
par contre il continue à pratiquer à
l'extérieur parce que des cheveux monde
d'être en forme physiquement pour faire
le job il ya plein de sites qui incite
des jeunes s'ils veulent partir il faut
qu'il soit en forme physiquement
deuxième la deuxième catégorie et ça
voulait peut-être pas dit c'est le
communautarisme
effectivement les notes et la note de
2015 du service central des
renseignements territoriaux disent que
le sport amateur et vecteur de
communautarisme et de radicalité ils
disent pas radicalisation et 10
radicalité c'est quoi la différence
il ya une grande confusion la radicalité
ça fait référence à l'islam rade alors
intégral et radicale c'est à dire que
tous les préceptes de l'idéologie de la
religion
de l'islam doit se retrouver dans tous
les espaces de la société à l'école dans
les prisons dans les clubs et donc c'est
le fait par exemple de faire des abus
sion de faire des prières dans les
espaces qui ne sont pas des espaces
culturels comme les vestiaires et a donc
on même sur les terrains ou même sur le
terrain et donc ce que je voulais dire
c'est qu'il y a donc la radicalisation
on peut en parler par la suite c'est un
phénomène à part il ya des liens entre
les deux que je dont je vous parlais le
communautarisme c'est encore autre chose
parce qu'il faut pas il faut peut-être
distingué aussi là dedans ce qu'on
appelle le sport communautaire qui a
toujours existé en france il ya toujours
eu des clubs catholiques eux des clubs
est d'ailleurs mois en alsace moselle
vous savez on connaît très bien on est
dans un régime concordataire jusque dans
les années 70 des protestants et des
catholiques avec des clubs séparés
voilà est un gamin protestants n'a même
pas le droit de pratiquer dans le club
de basket catholique donc on a un
phénomène
les clubs portugais s'est immolé afrique
vous avez des classes et sont ouverts
mais qui sont communautaristes a refusé
ses enfants il y est le problème c'est
que vous avez un centre de clubs
aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent rejeter celui
qui ne relève alors de l'entendre du
club on garde du club de quoi on parle
de clubs de football ça va peut être le
foot ça peut être parce qu'une
réparation il ya une déclaration il n'y
a pas très longtemps de la ministre des
sports il s'agit de roxana maracineanu
qui dit qu'elle se concentre sur sur
certains sports notamment le tir
regardez cette cette déclaration la voit
ici à l'image la ministre des sports en
portent spécifiquement notre attention
sur les sports de combat et ceux où on
apprend à utiliser des armes comme le
tir mais aussi là où on peut facilement
embrigader des groupes c'est à dire les
sports collectifs à commencer par par le
football alors le football je précise
quand même hein il ya du foot seul où
effectivement on a eu des remontées de
prosélytisme dans le futsal qui est un
peu moins contrôlé le football alors le
football c'est le premier sport
populaire en france il ya plus de 2000
ans licencié donc et qui est très
présent dans la région île de france par
exemple c'est le premier en terme de
licenciés c'est la première pratique et
dont le bilan est ce qu on fait beaucoup
de jeunes et les phénomènes de
radicalisation sur le terrain il ya des
moyens là qui ont été mis en place par
le maire avec 200 agents du ministère
formés à la lutte contre la
radicalisation
cinq mille interventions en 2019 est-ce
que ça suffira
regardez là il faut il faut se mettre
d'accord aujourd'hui le ministère des
sports qui vient sur le tard un sur ces
phénomènes là jusqu'à présent c'était le
ministère de l'intérieur qui est en
première ligne sur ces questions le
ministère de l'intérieur avait fait de
nos clubs de mouvement sportif en fait
son terrain de chasse son terrain de jeu
dans le ministère des sports contraint
et forcé a commencé à aborder la
question mais non pas sous l'angle de la
radicalisation va faire tomber des clubs
on va fermer des clubs non pas sous
l'eau l'appellation des clubs avec des
pratiques de communautarisme ou deux
radicalisation mais parce qu'on ira
chercher problèmes liés par exemple à la
sécurité des pratiquants un problème lié
à la vétusté des locaux
on ira donc comme pour al capone qui est
tombée sur pour d'autres raisons que ce
qu'il faisait et ce pour quoi on voulait
le faire alors si les clubs aujourd'hui
le ministère des sports et les agents du
ministère des sports qui sont en charge
du contrôle de ces clubs du contrôle de
ce mouvement sportif travaille sur un
autre sur un autre sur un axe j'allais
dire qui relèvent du code des sports et
pas du ministère de l'intérieur et
ancien intérieur ils sont aguerris
braillard avait dit ce n'est pas mon
rôle c'est celui du ministère de
l'intérieur il avait dit ça c'est bien
ça c'est à dire 4 octobre 2007 tragique
parce qu'on sait que depuis bien avant
secrétaire d'état aux sports wii que ce
soit thierry breillat ou patrick kanner
il ya une sorte d' aveuglement sur ces
questions ils ont parce que c'est vrai
que le sport porte des valeurs c'est
vrai que entrer dedans dans un dans un
club
vous rentrez avec des valeurs enfin en
vous un culte des valeurs vous avez des
d'éducateurs qui vous donne j'allais
dire que vos cadres simplement il peut y
avoir des déviances la société s'invite
dans les clubs les déviances de la
société sa vie les dérives de la société
s'invite dans les clubs et ils s'étaient
faire preuve d' aveuglement que ne pas
considérer qu'on pouvait ces clubs
pouvaient être infiltré certaines
boissons à la presse que maintenant on
se penche sur la question alors qu'a eu
des notes précédentes
à l'époque pourquoi maintenant pourquoi
ça n'a pas été fait précédemment premier
des déclarations comme ça de patrick 2-1
braillard avant il ya eu des attentes en
mai il ya eu les attentats effectivement
et on analyse les réseaux il ya eu imera
déjà en 2012 à strasbourg à la meinau en
il ya eu dix jeunes qui sont la meinau
c'est un quartier populaire de
de ce résultat de foot et bien voilà qui
sont partis faire le djihad
personne n'a compris parce que personnes
qui attendaient alors moi je peux dire
une chose je travaille depuis trente ans
sur le sport dans les quartiers
populaires et sur le lien entre le sport
et l'immigration
dans les années 80 on ne voyait pas
c'est à dire que quand vous regardez les
jeunes issus de l'immigration maghrébine
des années 1980 dans les clubs de
football il n'y avait pas de
revendication si vous voulez identitaire
religieuse
c'est quelque chose qui ne s'est
pratiquement pas après une question
géopolitique il ya
l'islam alors c'est qu'apple elle
explique très bien dans les banlieues
l'islam il ya l'avènement dann in islam
de france
il ya des mouvements salafistes qui
s'installe progressivement et qui essaie
de faire du prosélytisme et tout ça
évolue dans les années 80 90 on a en
2000 on a des notes qui arrive où on
voit qu'il y a des cas de prosélytisme
2015 il y aller en 2005 les émeutes à
clichy et ensuite 2015 on a des analyses
attentats donc on a une toile de fond
est évidemment si dans la société
française si elle monte si vous voulez
de deux mouvements salafistes qui sont
dans les quartiers populaires on a
une des tentatives de rentrer dans des
associations culturelles cultuelles
culturelles sportives etc
ils en ont on a un phénomène qui se
développe et il mais il fallait du temps
pour voir ça parce que d'une part ça
n'existait pas et et d'autre part nous
en tout cas les sociologues qu'on
n'était pas armé non plus pour regarder
avec des lunettes si vous voulez
sociologique qui puisse voir ces
phénomènes s'est désabonné tard mais est
ce qu'on est et l'armée maintenant est
quelle solution je me permets de vous
couper on le regarde dans la deuxième
partie de l'émission
le trauma trop bien d'être de retour sur
le plateau de l'autre match pour parler
sport et radicalisation nous inviter
sont toujours présents sur ce plateau
william gasparini sociologue professeur
à l'université de strasbourg à vos côtés
patrick karam vice président de la
région ile de france en charge des
sports
comment lutter contre la radicalisation
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
castaner s'était exprimé face aux
préfets c'était en novembre dernier
coûte l islamisme bien souvent tente
d'endoctriner notre jeunesse
il tente de séduire les plus faibles les
plus exposés il semble offrir bien
souvent un sens et une sociabilisation
qui manquent
dès qu'il existe des doutes sur un lieu
où sur une association je vous demande
de ne pas hésiter à réaliser des
inspections des contrôles et si des
manquements sont établis je vous demande
de décider des fermetures
administratives sans hésiter les
atteintes à la république doivent être
identifiés elles doivent être
sanctionnées
christophe castaner qui appelle à des
visites densification des sanctions agir
rapidement va ici par respect pour les
victimes on ne va pas mentionné les noms
des terroristes ni les disciplines
qu'ils pratiquaient mais on sait qu'il
pratiquait du football de la boxe thaï
du mma de la lutte est serrée et c'est
vous sur le terrain concrètement patrick
karam qu'est ce que vous faites pour
lutter contre ce phénomène de la réalise
la région a mis en place avec valérie
pécresse nous avons mis en place un vrai
plan depuis 2007 un plan de formation
des lanceurs d'alert qui nous
aujourd'hui sont opérationnels sur le
terrain et nous allons à mes témoins de
vous couper les 20 ans de la convention
et comment être sûr que ces lanceurs d
alerte ne sont pas eux-mêmes un film
soit à l'indignation la vie il n'ya pas
très longtemps
seize personnes être écarté des services
de renseignement par proximité avec la
raideur il y avait quelqu'un qui est
radicalisée vous le savez vous le savez
parce qu'il dégage il ya un certain
nombre de signaux que vous pouvez
interprété dans son comportement
le mouvement sportif effectivement
jusqu'à présent jusqu'à ce que nous on
commence cette formation reçue de l'état
était très en retard sur ces
questions-là en 2016 - sportif considéré
que ce n'était pas son affaire j'ai
expliqué qu'il s'agissait simplement de
jouer le rôle éducatif et de protéger
des gamins qu'on mettait des mineurs qui
étaient chez eux par des parents
aujourd'hui ce mouvement sportif
francilien totalement conscient que
c'est important et qu'il faut avancer
nous avons mis en place avec médéric
chapiteau qui est un expert de ces
questions
nancy un jean marie au ministère des
sports qui était même dtn adjoint sur un
certain nombre de faits d donc des fédés
de combat et il a écrit le sport une
faille dans la sécurité de l'état aux
éditions d'aidé qui utilisent quoi
doctorants ou docteur sur ces les docks
temps il tendrait sur les questions mais
il a une vision sécuritaire que moi je
dénonce un peu je pense qu elle pas
suffisamment sociologique
alors bon ça c est votre appréciation
mais revenons en tout cas sur ce que
nous avons pu mettre en place nous avons
mis en place donc ce cessez lanceur d
alerte choisi par les nouveaux le
mouvement la tête de réseau les ligues
régionales ou les comités régionaux
ils sont formés par nos formes et à
déceler et identifier ses cadres
radicalisation ça c'était la première
étape nous allons passer à une deuxième
étape parce que le sujet c'est
qu'aujourd'hui toute une série de
phénomènes nous échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui secret en
dehors du mouvement organisé ça veut
dire que c'est des gens qui sont là pour
aller faire du sport ensemble qui se
retrouvent pour aller faire du paintball
du softball
c'est à dire tout ce qui permet de vous
déplacer et puis d'avoir de l'agilité
des réflexes qui s'ils se retrouvent
pour créer des clubs de mma et qui
demande à une mairie des salles pour
pouvoir s'entraîner et les maires et
même à passer dans le giron de l'ocs
signal de la volonté et les maires
peuvent donner peuvent donner cette
autorisation là et bien aujourd'hui nous
allons former les maires les adjoints
leurs adjoints mais aussi le personnel
nous aurons des formations peau les
habitués à identifier un certain nombre
de dindes hills et de façon à pouvoir
lancer en grand système de lanceurs
d'alert ce que nous voulons c'est
étoffer ce que nous avons mis en place
avec le mouvement sportif crée aussi des
formateurs de formateurs pour que ça
puisse descendre jusqu'aux clubs par une
sonnerie et aujourd'hui nous avons un
problème c'est que l'état ne nous répond
pas ce coup là il faut qu'on se dise
maintenant les choses mais c'est le coup
de gueule du jour quand non quand il y à
des signalements de personnes ça peut
être un éducateur ça peut être un
pratiquant ça peut être un dirigeant
quand c'est l'éducateur c'est en même
temps compliquée l'éducateur lui il est
en lien avec les enfants il un poids sur
les enfants c'est à dire que vous
donneront les anciennes danses et le
manque de dialogue entre l'état des
sujets et quand il ya un dialogue entre
le mouvement sportif tel ligue et nos
services
eh bien vous avez une information
dissymétrique asymétrique
ça veut dire que vous n'avez pas le
retour tout de suite en réalité ils
prennent leur temps pour enquêter
peut-être mettre sur écoute et pendant
ce temps là la personne du jour dans le
club la personne agit toujours et c'est
vers un william gasparini vous qu'est ce
que vous voyez vous les voyez les
lanceurs d'alerté moi je suis pas dans
le champ de la prévention je suis pas
politique
voilà ce que peut dire le chercheur
c'est qu' il faut faire très attention
avec ce qu'on appelle les signaux
faibles parce que beaucoup de signes on
remonte sur de la pratique religieuse
qu'est ce que vous appelle les signaux
faibles
c'est le langage du domaine de la
prévention c'est par exemple le fait de
demander un repas halal dans lors d'un
déplacement pour des matchs de deux
jeunes c'est le fait de faire une prière
c'est l'effet sur dadis qui compte c'est
la multiplication des signaux faibles
qui dans les vestiaires essai d'avants
et désolé les signaux chaque signal en
soi ne signifie pas grand chose ça vous
le savez mais quand vous les cumuls et
là vous pouvez avoir peut-être des
indications sur ce que la personne est
en train de vivre
il ya beaucoup de remontées de deux de
ses signaux faibles
dans l'est dans les clubs et gagne
actuellement je pense qu'il faut
effectivement faire de la formation mais
il faut bien expliquer là parce que
j'explique avant les signaux keroman ce
sont des signaux de présence vers
religieuse que j'appelle moi de
l'intensification de la religiosité et
c'est vrai que c'est un phénomène
il faut faire de la prévention de
l'explication ne pas confondre un espace
du sport comme étant un espace cultuel
et ça même les les éducateurs de
confession musulmane le disent eux-mêmes
d'un certain âge parce que c'est un
phénomène qu'on en compte chez des
jeunes jeunes adultes surtout donc il
faut un vrai travail d'explication de
formation est ce que je dis aussi
souvent ces attentions
regardons aussi ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur des clubs puisque moi ce que
j'avais remarqué dans mon enquête c'est
que les aspirants djihadistes qui
voulaient partir devaient se forme et
être en forme physiquement parce que
sinon on ne les recrutait pas en syrie
et pour faire ça il fallait faire de
l'activité physique et donc qu'ils
allaient dans les salles de musculation
d'ailleurs le latin tanis cheval à la
personne pratiquer de la musculation
dans une salle privée et vous savez que
les salles privées sont contrôlés par le
ministère la jeunesse et des sports sont
contrôlés mais pas de la même manière
alors seulement est-ce qu'on va aller
qu'on a des pratiquants à l'extérieur
nous on a eu à proximité de strasbourg
dans la banlieue tchétchène qui s'est
radicalisée qui est parti il faisait la
pratique de suite' work outs et la
musculation de rue donc il ya moins de
contrôle sur beaucoup d'activités
extérieures
après c'est un phénomène qui est limité
les cas qui remonte souvent ce sont des
cas comme je dis plutôt de pratique
religieuse alors ensuite est-ce que ça
débouche sur de l'islam radical
ça c'est la vraie question parce que
c'est pas parce que effectivement on lit
le coran que forcément le jeune va
tomber dans la radicalisation voix soit
en sport on parlait de médéric chapiteau
en quoi le sport est une faille de
l'état sur les personnes qui sont
inscrits au fichier de pas le fichier s
l'autre fichiers sur la radicalisation à
visée terroriste
vous avez à peu près 10% 12% qui sont
dans des clubs ou dans des associations
sportives aujourd'hui
en fait le ces associations c'est des
lieux où ils fils entretiennent leur
forme physique ce sont des lieux aussi
ils peuvent parfois se retrouver
vous avez parfois des clubs qui se
créent et qui rejette tout ce qui n'est
pas par exemple avec des clubs qui
rejette des filles des ferries qui
rejette des personnes qui n'ont pas la
même religion
vous avez donc toute une série de
phénomènes qui peuvent exister mais ces
clubs là souvent ne relève pas d'une
fédération organisée je veux dire qu'ils
échappent au contrôle de l'état parce
que ce serait se sont créés sous un
angle purement associatif une
association loi 1901 phénomène qui est
alors qu'ils existent mais qui est
minoritaire de la même manière qu'il y à
des associations cultuelles qui organise
des tournois internes mosquée de
football il y à sa tombe de phénomènes
moi je dirais que c'est ça reste
minoritaire alors effectivement il faut
être attentif et vigilant mais on a
plutôt comme je le dis une montée de la
présence du religieux que dans les
années 80 ne rencontrait pas et j'ai
moi-même mardi religieux moi même je
twitte de la laïcité dans les lieux
sportifs ce sont des lieux publics
liberté égalité fraternité sont des
espaces félicité n'ya non qui doivent
être neutres et d'ailleurs le slogan du
sport c'est de dire que on laisse son
identité au vestiaire aujourd'hui la
région impose à tous ceux qu'elle
finance de respecter une charte laïcité
valeurs de la république et dans le
sport c'est aussi le cas de ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous avez est ce que
ça soit comme la charte
vous avez chanté la marseillaise
aujourd'hui alors pardon il faut que
tout ça soit sa compagne à la fois de
formation de sensibilisation et de
contrôle
le contrôle est extrêmement important et
le contrôle que nous nous voulons
développer c'est le contrôle du
mouvement sportif lui-même
je veux dire ne plus rien voir ne plus
rien attendre ça n'est plus possible et
c'est ça qui produira des résultats
parce qu'ils se parlent ils ont plus
confiance entre eux quand anvers en
agents de l'état c'est le premier pour
un deuxième point vous avez quand même
quelques dérives
quand on me raconte sportifs de haut
niveau me raconte qu'il est dans une
manifestation sportive je citerai pas la
discipline et qu'il mange un sandwich au
jambon et qu'un champion que nous
connaissons que nous admirons vient le
voir pour lui dire mais pourquoi tu
manges dudu delà du port ça n'est pas la
halle et qui lui dit mes mains je suis
pas musulman et que l'autre lui dit mais
si tu veux on peut apprendre et il sait
de lui imposer sa foi quand dans les
vestiaires vous voulez vous baigner nu
et qu'on vous dit non vous vous baignez
pas nu parce que il ya la pudeur et que
si vous parfois quand vous passez les
douches
quand vous voulez passer outre passé cet
ordre là vous fait tabasser c'est un
vrai problème
alors est ce que c'est de la
radicalisation pas encore pas forcément
encore mais en tout cas on a un
glissement on ne peut pas accepter le
passage à l'acte est ce le passage
justement il n'ya pas extrêmement enfin
très peu de sportifs qui passent à
l'acte parce qu'on n'a pas de cas comme
jeudi avant les les terroristes du
bataclan de nice et ce sont des
personnes qui s'il pratiquer du sport
c'était avant de rentrer dans la
procédure processus de radicalisation
c'est bien avant donc on a pas de cas de
passage à l'acte
le sport qui est radicale ici c'est ça
votre question retirer vos de la tête
que le sport à l'iss oui ça c'est pas le
sujet par contre le score d'utilisateurs
auraient indique alizés maintenant
radicalise par le sport vous permet
d'être en forme et peut-être que ce cas
là que vous allez retrouver pense que le
copain tout à fait je pense qu'il ya eu
un moment certains ont dit le sport
amateur c'est le premier lieu vecteur de
radicalisation c'est faux c'est la
prison ça a été montrée vous lisez
l'ouvragé qui vient de paraître de hugo
misseron kiki qui montre très bien que
dans les prisons considéré comme l'ena
de la radicalisation au sénat on forme
dans les clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
effectivement il peut y en avoir mais
pas contre les radicaliser de la même
manière qu'ils quittent ne vont plus à
la mosquée ils ne sont plus à l'école ne
sont plus dans les clubs
il était avant alors effectivement vous
avez le tueur de l'hyper cash a par
exemple
qui lui pratiquer de la boxe et il était
même coach dans une salle dans une vidéo
post mortem
il appelait les musulmans sportif de
france à se rebeller à contrer la
république française donc il ya eu des
appels mais une fois qu'il est rentré
dans le processus il a quitté le club
oui mais à force et c'est là qu'il
disloquait le reste oui du coup
d'haltères messieurs mais avant tout
récemment le mode la wii vous avez
absolument gratifie totalement votre
navire le maître public sadran qui le
quittent le club
il émet un certain de signaux faibles
dans son comportement lorsqu'il a changé
et c'est nous ce que nous essayons
d'identifier aujourd'hui en ile de
france c'est ce changement de
comportement qui peut entraîner ce
glissement et ça c'est extrêmement
important
alors allez-y mon seul mot de la fin je
dans la grande majorité
le club sportif réf reste tout de même
un lieu d'intégration de mixité pour
beaucoup de footballeurs de jeunes qui
font des sports populaires et qui sont
de confession musulmane ça il faut pas
l'oublier et quelques cas mais je pense
qu'il faut pas oublier que le brassard
garde amalgame se fait bien dans les
clubs et aux fondateurs et peuvent aussi
délicieux merci messieurs dans ce
constat d'être venu sur le plateau de
l'autre match pourrait bloquer donc
cette problématique de la radicalisation
dans le sport une émission à retrouver
sur notre site internet arte france
point tv en podcast est en replay
et ne manquez pas évidemment un prochain
numéro de l'autre match la semaine
prochaine bah bail
[Musique]